Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat entschieden, dass die Vereine der DFL an Mehrkosten für Polizeieinsätze bei Hochrisikospielen beteiligt werden sollen. Ihr habt es wahrscheinlich mitbekommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Aber vielleicht habt ihr euch auch gefragt, was bedeutet das jetzt eigentlich und wie ist es dazu gekommen? Diese Fragen und noch weitere werden wir jetzt hier besprechen. Und ich habe dafür eine tolle Runde hier. Philipp Maume und Fabian Reinholz. Ich stelle sie euch gleich vor. Jetzt geht's los hier im Rasenfunk. Ertes Publikum, der Rasenfunk.
Bei diesen Risikospielen da kommen dann Hooligans. Und die wollen sich einfach prügeln, die wollen in die möglicherweise Innenstädte in Schutt und Asche legen.
Gerade wenn auch manche etwas schwierigen Fußball-Kaoten aus Ostdeutschland beispielsweise bei Spielen in Bayern anreisen, ein Mindest so großen Polizeiansatz wie bei einem großen Spiel des FC Bayern.
Ehrlich gesagt, die Frage kann ich nicht beantworten. Ich kann mir auch, ich kann letztlich auch nicht ganz beantworten, wie es zu diesen Zahlen kommt. Aber fragt beispielsweise mal Strafrechtskollegen, welche Straftaten dann überhaupt eigentlich in diese Statistik einfließen. Also ich hab jetzt wirklich nur vage, ich bin kein Strafrechtler, aber der Landfriedensbruch, der ist ja ein Tatbestand, der möglicherweise dann schon erfüllt ist, wenn man sich in einer Gruppierung aufhält, die Gewalthandlungen außerhalb des Stadionbereichs ausübt, aber wo man selber jetzt nicht auch unmittelbar beteiligt ist, kann man möglicherweise relativ schnell dort in diese Statistik reinkommen und dadurch sich dann auch die Zahlen exorbitant erhöhen. Aber ja, also die Einschätzung nochmal, wir hatten das ja vorhin schon besprochen, die Einschätzung anhand der Zahlen und anhand dessen, was in der Vergangenheit geschehen ist, vorzunehmen, ist schwierig. Und soweit jedenfalls man diese Einschätzung den Behörden überlässt, muss man einfach damit rechnen, dass diese im Zweifel immer das Risiko zu hoch einschätzen. Also es tatsächlich ist, übrigens warum auch, weil sie natürlich im Zweifel dann später rechtfertigen müssen, warum sie dann Gewaltmaßnahmen, die dann entstanden sind, nicht verhindern konnten. Und da ist dann, das ist natürlich auch eine hochpolitische Geschichte, weil da können dann im Zweifel innerhalb der Behörden dann irgendwie auch mal Köpfe rollen. Und da möchte natürlich keiner derjenige sein, der da am Kreuz vorher steht, dann insbesondere vielleicht auch noch öffentlich. Und wird dann eben im Zweifel lieber einfach auf das Motto setzen, Vorsicht ist die Mutter der Porzellankiste.
Und eigentlich möchte man das ja auch als Gesellschaft würde ich mal annehmen. Also das zum Beispiel bei den wirklich nicht schönen Bildern aus Hamburg, wo eben die Hamburg-Fans auf Rentner und ein Kind soll auch mit dabei gewesen sein, eingeprügelt haben auf St. Pauli, dass das sich so schnell beruhigt hat, hatte ganz sicher auch damit zu tun, dass nach allem, was ich gehört habe, die Polizei rundert schafft oder zumindest ein kleiner Einsatztrupp, der war in der Straße nebenan, die sind dazwischen gegangen und dann war das nach einer Minute vorbei. Und das ist ja das, was wir wollen. Wir wollen ja Sicherheit und wir wollen, dass wenn es mal knallt, schlimm genug, dass es knallt, aber so ist es leider, wird sich nie ganz verhindern lassen, dann wollen wir ja auch Sicherheit haben und dafür ist die Polizei da. Aber gleichzeitig empfindet man ja auch Philipp als Fußballfan bzw. es ist, glaube ich, nicht nur ein subjektives Empfinden, sondern es lässt sich auch mit Zahlen belegen, dass aber gerade weil Fußballfans so ein gutes Opfer sind, weil sie die bösen Buben sind, in Anführungszeichen, es ist sehr einfach ein Bild zu zeichnen von eben den Chaoten, die Innenstädte in Schutt und Asche legen, so dass es eben sogar bei reflektierten Menschen dann sich verfängt in den Köpfen. Gerade deswegen erlebt man ja auch immer wieder, dass Fußballfans durchaus auch Versuchskaninchen sind für Einsatztaktiken, jetzt hat der zuständige Polizeischiff gewechselt und fährt mal einen härteren Kurs oder zum Beispiel im Rahmen der Europameisterschaft hatten wir auf einmal wirklich Grenzüberschreitungen der Polizei gegenüber der Gesellschaft, in dem Fall dann Fußballfans, die eben auch sehr kritisch zu sehen waren. Wir haben Überwachungsmaßnahmen, die immer wieder gerne im Kontext des Fußballs ausprobiert werden wollen, unter anderem auch bei der EM 2024, wo jeder Ticketinhaber und man kam nur über die EM-App ins Stadion. Der Aufenthalt dort jedes Ticketinhabers war zwar anonymisiert, aber er war sichtbar für die Einsatzzentralen. Das wurde einfach so nebenher mal berichtet in einem Bericht des Bayerischen Rundfunks. Und das ist ja die Ebene, die glaube ich dann zum Beispiel Fanvertreter haben, wie unsere Kurve, die dann auch in ihrem Statement zu hören sind. Ich spiele das noch mal kurz ein, wie jetzt dann die Lage der Nation darauf reagiert hat. Es tut mir ein bisschen leid, dass ich jetzt Philipp Banzer und Ulf Burma hier so raushebe. Ich habe auch noch andere O-Töne, aber die passen immer am besten, um zu zeigen, wie denken Menschen darüber, die nicht so tief im Fußball sind. Und Philipp, du darfst dann gerne mal ihnen das erklären, was sie nicht verstanden haben.
Also Fanorganisationen reagieren entsetzt auf dieses Urteil. Sie sehen in dieser Entscheidung ein Präzedenzfall und ein Freifahrtschein für eine immer aggressive und martialische auftretende Polizei. Freifahrtschein, warum den Zusammenhang verstehe ich nicht. Also nur weil die Polizei aus einer anderen Quelle bezahlt wird, tritt sich martialischer auf. Ich habe das auch nicht so ganz verstanden. Also das erschließt sich mir so spontan nicht.
Da tue ich mich jetzt auch ein bisschen schwer. Also ich will ganz ehrlich sein, denn das staatliche, also vielleicht muss man auch mal klarstellen, am staatlichen Gewaltmonopol ändert sich gar nichts. Am staatlichen Auftrag ändert sich gar nichts. Worüber man mal reden könnte oder da müsste man vielleicht mal eine Evaluation starten, keine Ahnung, ob sich, wenn die Polizei-Präsidenten drei Jahre lang sich gewissermaßen Geld ganz oder teilweise wiederholen können, ob sich dann tatsächlich was an ihrem Verhalten ändert. Das können wir dann gerne mal empirisch untersuchen, aber eigentlich ändert, also mich überzeugt das, also tut mir leid, wenn ich dich da enttäuschen muss, gar nicht. Da würde ich dich, mich deinen Podcast-Kollegen mal anschließen.
Ja, ich glaube die Korsalkette, dass es jetzt wegen dieser Entscheidung martialischer würde, das halte ich auch für falsch. Ich glaube aber, das ist nicht das, was die Fans sagen wollten. Ich glaube die Fans wollten sagen, wir erleben jetzt schon, dass es immer martialischer wird, dass wir im Zweifel eher zwei Wasserwerfer gegen uns positioniert sind als einen Wasserwerfer. Dass wir zum Teil Bereitschaftspolizistinnen und Polizisten aus anderen Bundesländern haben, die dann für Sicherheit sorgen sollen, bei denen das Gefühl der Unsicherheit wächst und das manchmal auch aus guten Gründen. Es gibt auch Fälle von Polizeigewalt, ohne dass sich das eine mit dem anderen gleichsetzen möchte, aber das eine wird strafrechtlich viel weniger verfolgt als das andere. Und dass quasi diese Tendenz, die die Fans wahrnehmen, die ich in Teilen auch unterstützen würde, ich hab's rund um im Vorfeld der EM fand ich, war das durchaus zu beobachten, dass das unterstützt wird, wenn es jetzt auch noch gezahlt wird. Ich glaube, das ist das, was Sie sagen wollen.
Okay, gut. Aber ganz kurz dazu, da sind wir wieder auf der politischen Ebene. Ich meine, dass diese Entscheidung als Dammbruch, ich meine, dass das Gericht sagt, man darf es so machen, aber wir sagen nicht, man soll es so machen. Und dann das Gericht als Dammbruch, das spricht nur Recht. Also sagt, okay, das ist nach geltender Rechtslage, aber mehr sagen wir dazu auch nicht. Und das ist da deshalb nicht das Dammbruch-Argument ein bisschen schwierig an dieser Stelle. Das soll es uns verfassungsrecht sagen. Soll es dann sagen, wir machen jetzt eine andere Meinung oder irgendwas juristisch schwerer haltbares. Näsien scheinen ja nur diesen Fall. Aber da sehe ich jetzt als Hochschullehrer drauf und nicht als jemand, der das dann praktisch begleitet. Aber ich glaube, ich habe Fabian gerade so ein bisschen abgeschnitten.
Gar nicht. Ich will nur tatsächlich da auch noch was zu einwerfen. Ich sehe das ganz ähnlich wie du, Max. Weil ich glaube auch, dass die Fans nicht damit meinen, dass jetzt die Polizei diese Entscheidung zum Anlass nimmt, dann dann mal ordentlich auf die Fresse zu hauen. Aber dass natürlich ein besonderes Maß an Polizeiaufgebot und besondere Einsatzszenarien auch Situationen zuspitzen können. Und damit vielleicht dann eben auch Gewalt sozusagen mitbegründend sind, das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen. Ich kann mich zum Beispiel erinnern, ich hab früher in der Nähe von Görlitzer Bahnhof hier in Berlin gewohnt, in der Pücklerstraße und da war zum 1. Mai war da immer richtig Bambule. Und ich konnte das, konnte ich von der WG, die ich da hatte, konnte ich das sogar von der Terrasse aus alles sehen, was da passierte. Da brannten auch Autos und so weiter. Und ich erinnere mich, dass ich einmal, da kam ich irgendwie nach Hause zurück, bieg um die Ecke und plötzlich kommt mir ein Wasserwerfer entgegen. Und das ist schon ein komisches Gefühl, weil so ein Wasserwerfer ist ein richtig fettes Ding. Das sieht aus wie ein Panzer. Und wenig später war dann irgendwie noch eine Polizeisperre, bei der ich dann nachweisen musste, dass ich da wohne und da Vorlage meines Ausweises und so. Und ich will jetzt sagen, das hat mich jetzt alles nicht nachhaltig belastet, aber es ist ein komisches Gefühl. Und da kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das auch für Fans, die gar keine Absichten in Richtung Gewalt haben, dass das vielleicht auch schon irgendwo kritisch, berechtigterweise kritisch wahrgenommen wird, wenn man dann vielleicht plötzlich eingekesselt ist oder wenn dann so eine Gerätschaften da auffahren. So verstehe ich die Fan-Äußerungen und ich glaube, dass da im Lage der Nation tatsächlich das nicht ganz richtig gewürdigt hat.
Ja, aber da muss ich gleich mal wieder reden. Die würden aber trotzdem stehen, die Wasserwerfer. Also die Gefahr, die ich sehe, ist, dass die Politik das jetzt gewissermaßen als Freibrief nehmen könnte und nicht als Freibrief, aber jetzt so, ha, jetzt, also wir können's, jetzt machen wir's auch. Und wir haben ja auch jetzt bald Wahlen, bei denen es ja auch immer einiges gibt, die nächste Landtagswahl in Bayern kommt auch. Max, du weißt immer, was dann hier passiert. Aber die würden da doch trotzdem stehen. Also diese Kausalkette aus Urteil und jetzt, also die sieht halt nicht.
Aber glaubst du, es ist wahrscheinlicher geworden, dass vielleicht jetzt mal bei einem Spiel kein Wasser war, versteht, bei einem Hochrisikospiel. Also dass wir die Spirale vielleicht zurückdrehen. Ja und darum geht's, glaube ich. Dass quasi damit jetzt klar ist, es wird nicht mehr zurückgehen hinter den Standard, der jetzt herrscht und den kann man aus sehr, sehr guten kritisieren. Für den gibt es auch gute Gründe, dass es ihn gibt. Aber ich glaube, das ist das, was gemeint ist. Es wird jetzt nicht zurückgehen. Es wird nicht zu weniger Polizeipräsenz führen, sondern tendenziell und das erscheint mir schon relativ logisch, eher zu mehr, weil es jetzt ein bisschen einfacher zu verargumentieren ist und auch zu entscheiden. Ich meine, all die Arbeitsstunden, die da geleistet werden, die Überstunden, die Polizistinnen und Polizisten aufbauen, das ist ja völlig grotesk. Die sind ja auch völlig underequipped und so weiter und so fort. Obwohl man das beim Fußball nicht so sieht, weil da hast du immer das neueste Wasserwerferding stehen. Das ist ja auch ein guter Grund, etwas anzuschaffen. Und genau da sind wir in der Thematik. Und ich glaube darum geht es, dass man eine durchaus... Aufrüstung ist ein schwieriges Wort, weil es sehr martialisch klingt, aber eine sehr, sehr große erhöhte Präsenz von Polizeigerätschaften und auch Personen rund um Fußballfans, Fußballspiele wahrnimmt in den letzten Jahren. Und dass das jetzt noch mal zurückgehen würde und es gibt ja auch durchaus auch wissenschaftliche Untersuchungen, die davon ausgehen, eine geringere Polizeipräsenz kann. Sie muss nicht, aber sie kann auch zu einem erhöhten Sicherheitsgefühl führen und auch mit einer geringeren Polizeipräsenz können auch Fußballspiele sicher durchgeführt werden. Der Zugang zu dieser Welt wird ja ein bisschen schwerer gemacht, wenn man es jetzt bezahlt bekommt.
Und jetzt muss man ja auch ganz klar sagen, also dieser Rechtsweg, der hinter den Beteiligten liegt, der hatte ja ein Ergebnis, das war Hopp oder Top. Das heißt also, wenn das Bundesverfassungsgericht eine andere Auffassung gewesen wäre, hätte das dazu geführt, dass Land Bremen und gegebenenfalls welche, die da nachziehen, gar keine Gebühren für mehr Einsatz hätten verlangen können. Und jetzt können sie es aber und dann ist doch die Rechnung eigentlich ganz einfach. Die sagen sich, naja, so einen Wasserwerfer kriege ich vielleicht auf jeden Fall abgerechnet und dann stelle ich doch vielleicht noch mal einen zweiten dazu. Und wenn ich den am Ende nicht abgerechnet kriege, weil mir dann im Verwaltungsverfahren dann doch rechtlich dabeise vorgehalten wird, das war jetzt aber too much, dann habe ich doch zumindest irgendwie die Hälfte meiner Einsatzkosten raus. Und ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass diese Kalkulationsgrundlage eben dann doch dazu führt, dass ich im Zweifel da bei den Maßnahmen den Maßstab ein bisschen lockerer anlege.
Ja, das ist nicht. Ja, da kann man schwer was dagegen sagen. Und Maxi, ich stimme auch dir zu, dass die Entscheidung passt natürlich so in den generellen gesellschaftlichen Flow, Sicherheitsgefühl und so weiter und so fort. Und das Gericht hat eben nicht die Bremse reingehauen und zu sagen, so geht es jetzt aber nicht. Nur ist das vielleicht auch eine Wahrnehmung an die Gerichte oder in dem Fall das Bundesverfassungsgericht. Und das sieht man in vielen, vielen Bereichen, sind das Erwartungen, die dann vielleicht schief oder irgendwie überzogen sind. Weil wie gesagt, ich dreh mich so ein bisschen im Kreis. Wie gesagt, die sagen nur, dass man darf.
Eigentlich soll das Bundesverfassungsgericht nicht diesem Flock einhauen, sondern es soll nur diesen Fall beurteilen.
Genau. Und ich stimme dir zu, das Rad werden wir nicht zurückdrehen, aber das hätte eigentlich das Bundesverfassungsgericht auch nur, also wenn sie es getan hätten, dann hätten sie aber mit ganz vielen anderen Sachen wohl sich auf glattes Eis begeben. Also ich bleibe dabei, es ist halt eine politische Frage und da wird es halt interessant.
Und es wird vor allem eher interessant in der Berichterstattung über ein solches Urteil. Ich finde da sind wir jetzt nämlich gerade beim springenden Punkt. Ich habe das vorhin schon mal in einem Nebensatz erwähnt, dass ich den Eindruck habe, dass es sehr einfach ist, über dieses Urteil zu sprechen und sich dazu eine Meinung zu bilden, aber sehr sehr schwer ist, über die dahinter liegenden Bewegungen in unserer Gesellschaft zu sprechen. Also eben das, was ich vorhin schon angesprochen habe. Es sind überdurchschnittlich Männer, die Gewalttaten rund um den Fußball, aber eben nicht nur im Fußball vollführen. Alkohol spielt eine ganz ganz wichtige Rolle, auch andere Drogen bei der BG und dieser Straftaten. Und wir sehen eine zunehmende Radikalisierung und die sehen wir eben nicht nur im Fußball. Wir haben das immer wieder, wenn sich Nazis im Kurven durchsetzen und äußern, dass wir dann immer wieder an den Punkt kommen, dass wir sagen, ja wie soll der Fußball auch einer gesellschaftlichen Gesamtentwicklung, wo manche jetzt aus ihren Löchern kommen und Dinge sagen, die nicht sagbar waren noch vor ein paar Jahren, wie soll der Fußball sich dem entgegenstellen? Fabian, ist das nicht eigentlich die Diskussion, die man führen müsste? Denn auch allein monetär gesehen bezahlt die Gesellschaft ja so oder so. Entweder bezahlt die Gesellschaft alle Polizeieinsätze, auch bei Hochrisikospielen. Dann wird es auf die Schultern aller verteilt. Oder wir haben eben die Fußballvereine, die ihr Geld woher bekommen? Über Sponsoren und über TV-Gelder, was übrigens auch nach meinem Wissen nach Bürgerinnen und Bürgern dieses Landes bezahlen. Also es läuft nur einen anderen Weg. Plus wahrscheinlich ist es jetzt noch ein bisschen leichter, mehr auszugeben auf Seiten der Polizei, weil man es eben wiederbekommt, die gerade eben geführte Diskussion. Also sprich, am Ende ist diese Zufriedenheit, die manche nicht Fußballfans haben. Endlich werden die mal zur Kasse geboten. Mir scheint das so ein bisschen ein Druckschluss zu sein. Und auch die eigentlich interessante Debatte, was ist denn eigentlich gesamtgesellschaftlich vielleicht zu erkennen an diesem Problem im Fußball, die wird dadurch so ein bisschen überlagert.
Ja, also die Gedanken hab ich mir natürlich auch gemacht und es wäre wahrscheinlich ein Weg gewesen, dass man sich bei Zeiten und wie gesagt diese Diskussion darum wäre, da die Kosten zu tragen hat, die ist ja schon älter als zehn Jahre, dass man sich vielleicht bei Zeiten unter den sogenannten Stakeholdern Gedanken darüber gemacht hätte, wie man in Ansehung dieser dann doch ja teilweise schon auch notwendigen Kosten, wie man die umlegt und wie man eine Lösung dafür findet, dass sagen wir mal, sich alle Beteiligten, die begünstigt sind oder darunter leiden, irgendwo wohlfühlen. Also Stichwort, irgendein Fonds. Ich kann mich jetzt nicht mehr so gut dran erinnern, ob diese Vorschläge schon mal tatsächlich auf dem Tisch waren oder wie die wieder behandelt wurden. Aber natürlich könnte man sich überlegen, ob nicht die Allgemeinheit plus die DFL beziehungsweise die beteiligten Vereine einfach einen Topf dafür machen, dass man solche Einsätze in Zukunft bezahlen kann.
Und wenn man teammarktwert ist, dann muss man ein bisschen mehr zahlen, wenn man Fans hat. Da bewegen wir uns gleich auf die nächste Debatte zu.
Also eine Fondslösung wurde durchaus vorgeschlagen von Ulrich Meurer direkt nach der Urteilsverkündung. Er meinte damit aber ein Fonds innerhalb der DFL, denn das ist jetzt noch so ein Nebenthema, das haben wir ausgespart, das ja aktuell jetzt erstmal nur Werder Bremen betrifft, aber eben es jetzt wahrscheinlich auch sein kann, dass es auch in anderen Bundesländern kommt, aber vielleicht ja auch in Bundesländern, die gar keinen Bundesligisten haben oder weniger Hochrisikospiele und dann eben die Frage ist, zahlt es die Gemeinschaft der DFL-Vereine oder wird da jeder einzelne Verein von der DFL dann wiederum zur Kasse gebeten? Aber das ist eine Diskussion, die sollen die führen. Also das ist, ich finde, das muss nicht unsere sein. Aber ist es nicht interessant, dass wir es eigentlich nicht schaffen, auf das Größerliegende zu blicken, weil es da auch keine klaren, also weil die Befunde schwieriger zu treffen sind und vor allem Gegenmaßnahmen auch schwieriger sind. Also wie willst du männlich geprägte Gewalt aus der Gesellschaft kriegen? Da habe ich jetzt natürlich auch kein Rezept. Aber eigentlich ist es doch auch ein Ergebnis dessen. Also die Fans nehmen Fußball zum Anlass, um sich zu prügeln. Und manchmal ist das vielleicht auch der Grund, warum sie sich prügeln. Manchmal wollen sie sich aber vielleicht auch einfach nur prügeln. Und müsste man nicht die Frage stellen, wie man mit solchen Menschen in der Gesellschaft umgeht, wie man das vielleicht schafft, für die Allgemeinheit verträglicher zu machen und vielleicht auch manchen dazu zu bringen, das nicht zu tun. Und ich glaube nicht, dass das mit diesen Polizeikosten urteilt. Also die Chaoten werden nicht aufhören, sich jetzt zu prügeln.
Leider. Ja, das stimmt. Ich kann mich aber daran erinnern, dass ich in meinem Studium das Wahlfach Kriminologie hatte. Und da war das schon ein Thema. Und als ich studiert habe, war es aber auch schon 20 Jahre vorher ein Thema gewesen, dass die Fangewalt eben einen soziologischen Aspekt hat und ein ganz vielschichtiges Thema ist. Also klassischerweise könnte man ja sagen, naja, dann sollen die sich doch prügeln. Und man fühlt sie dann irgendwie auf ein eingehegtes Feld. Und da können sie dann machen, was sie wollen. Und wer zuschauen will, guckt sich das eben an. Oder ansonsten nicht, aber es betrifft dann die Allgemeinheit nicht. Nur so funktioniert das in der Praxis eben gar nicht. Und ja, wie gesagt, sucht man das Gespräch mit Fanforschern, mit Kriminologen, die sich um dieses Phänomen Gedanken machen. Und das schon seit Jahren wird man feststellen, dass es eben dafür keine Lösung gibt, die man am Reißbrett so entwerfen kann. Das ist, das gehört sozusagen auch zur Gesellschaft dazu, dass sich diese Form der Gewaltbereitschaft auf diese Art und Weise entladen. Und damit will ich sagen, ich hab da keine Lösung parat und ich hätte auch gewisse Zweifel, dass man jetzt auch einmal nach dieser Entscheidung so viel Kräfte mobilisieren kann, dass man das Problem innerhalb von zwei Jahren gelöst hat. Das glaube ich nicht.
Das wollte ich auch nicht ganz damit suggerieren. Philipp.
Ja, kann ich für dich hinzufügen. Ich meine, es ist einerseits ja fast schon, ich mach grad hier jetzt die Gänsefüße in dem Podcast, schön, dass sich das Ganze am Fußball entlädt. Das zeigt nämlich, was der Fußball für einen gesellschaftlichen Stellenwert haben. Dass diese Fragen dann halt anhand des Fußballs gestellt werden und diskutieren. Aber der Fußball kann sie halt nicht lösen. Und wir verwalten mit diesen Urteilen, mit den Polizeikosten und so weiter und so fort verwalten wir so ein bisschen den Mangel oder versuchen irgendwie flicken drauf zu machen auf gesellschaftliche Umstände. Und das werden wir hier nicht gelöst bekommen. Leider.
Wir drei sowieso nicht. Bei allem guten Willen. Aber und ich weiß ja auch, dass es auch super langweilig auch immer auf diese großen Themen zu kommen, für die es keine einfache Lösung gibt. Aber also es ist schon interessant zu sehen, dass es im Kleinen dann doch immer scheinbar pragmatische Lösungen gibt. Also zum Beispiel kennzeichnet ein Hochrisikospiel auch, dass es im Stadion oft nur alkoholfreies Bier gibt oder irgendwie niederprozentiges Bier. Löst das Problem nicht? Warum? Die Leute kommen schon vorher angeschossen rein und wer sich das teure Stadionbier kauft, der hat sowieso die Kontrolle über seinen Stadionbesuch verloren, wenn ihr mich fragt. Aber es ist ja interessant, dass hier eine Antwort auf Risiko und auf Gewalt ist und auf Übergriffe und auf Straftaten, Ordnungswidrigkeiten und so weiter und so fort. Wir schränken den Alkoholkonsum ein. Und dann endet aber hier die Diskussion. Und ich will jetzt, liebe Leute, ich will euch nicht das Bier wegnehmen. Bitte, bitte, ihr könnt die Fackeln wieder einpacken. Stellt euch nicht vor mein Haus. Das möchte ich nicht. Aber so eine grundsätzliche Diskussion könnte man schon drüber führen, was eben dann und da gibt es ja auch andere Stellschrauben. Zum Beispiel können wir sogar beim Fußball bleiben. Werbung für Alkohol im Fußball. Da hat sich ja schon mal was verändert. War noch in den 90ern anders als es jetzt ist und so weiter und so fort. Und ich finde es interessant, es ist erklärbar, sehr leicht erklärbar, warum diese Fragen nicht diskutiert werden, weil sie sind extrem komplex. Sie sind total unbequem und du musst den Leuten was wegnehmen. Das heißt, du bist quasi die Verkörperung der Grünen. Und das sage ich als jemand, der eben in dem Bundesland lebt, in dem niemand so schlimm ist wie die Grünen, wenn es zumindest nach Markus Söder geht. Aber eigentlich könnte es ja auch so weitergehen. Aber das ist eben leider hier auch nicht passiert.
Eine ganz konkrete Sache, die sich jetzt heraus ergeben kann. Dieses Urteil, das muss man auch sagen, betrifft der einzige Anwendungsfall dieses Urteils, es stand heute Werder Bremen. Und jetzt frage ich mich dran, wie geht denn jetzt Werder Bremen damit um? Eine ganz einfache Lösung wäre, die wir alle nicht wollen.
In die dritte Liege runtergehen.
Ich würde es nicht ganz so weit machen, aber ich hätte jetzt gesagt, aber nach dem wird es zwar auch wahrscheinlich ein bisschen anwenden können, aber die logische Vorgehensweise, man sagt, wir wollen jetzt diese in Zukunft, diese inzwischen sind es anscheinend über drei Millionen Euro, nicht zahlen bzw. wir wollen nicht, dass die DFL das von uns wiederholt. Also erstens müssen wir innerhalb der DFL dafür sorgen, nur sagen alle anderen 35 so, ja ich zuck grad meine Schultern hoch und die naheliegende Lösung wäre, dass jetzt keine Gästefans mit zugelassen werden bei Sachen, die problematisch sein könnten und das ist ja eine Konsequenz, mal ganz praktisch, wie nun wirklich keiner von uns will. Und ich rede jetzt ja nicht von Wolfsburg, das ist ja dieses absurde Beispiel, aber Hamburg-Fans, ja, finde ich ganz komplex.
Und vielleicht sind wir da gar nicht so weit von entfernt, denn Tarek Brauer, der Geschäftsführer für Personal und Organisation von Werder Bremen, der hat unter anderem im NDR das hier gesagt.
Jetzt im Liga-Verband und das ist meine Erwartungshaltung, werden wir Diskussionen führen müssen. Und zwar Diskussionen darum, dass Werder Bremen hier nicht allein ich die Zeche zahlen darf. Und meine Erwartungshaltung ist schon die, dass wir die Veranstalterrolle in Blick nehmen und dass wir das Verursacherprinzip in Blick nehmen. Denn es bleibt doch festzuhalten, dass die DFL mindestens eine Co-Veranstalterrolle hat. Und es bleibt auch festzuhalten, dass die Anhänger des Gastvereins durchaus dazu beitragen, dass ein Spiel ein Hochrisikospiel wird mit Kostenfolge. Und meine Erwartungshaltung ist, dass wir da nicht allein im Haftungsboot sitzen, sondern die DFL und der Gastverein mindestens genauso.
Also Philipp, als hättest du diesen O-Ton vorher schon...
Liebe Hörer, wir hatten das vorher nicht abgesprochen.
Wir hatten das vorher nicht abgesprochen. Aber genau, das sind die Diskussionen, die zu führen sind. Und das bringt mich eigentlich dann auch so ein bisschen zum Fazit oder zum Ausblick. Wir haben jetzt versucht zum Reisen, worum es hier geht, wie es dazu kam. Ich würde gern jetzt nochmal in aller Kürze eure Meinung zu diesem Urteil abfragen. Erstmal die Meinung, Dammbruch ja oder nein? Fabian, was würdest du sagen?
Vom Gefühl ehrlich gesagt eher nicht. Also Dammbruch in juristischer Hinsicht ja. In der Praxis könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass die Weihnachtsmärkte und das Oktoberfest aber nicht in einer Weise in die Verantwortung gezogen werden, wie es hier im professionellen Fußball der Fall ist.
Also sprich, die Anschlussfrage, die ich hätte stellen wollen, Lex.DFL, das ist ein klares Ja.
Ja.
Philipp, wie siehst du es? Dammbruch ja oder nein?
Ich würde es auch juristisch jetzt nicht so für einen Dammbruch halten, aber im Ergebnis würde ich genau sagen, was Fabian sagt, was jetzt halt nur nicht passieren dürfte. Und da könnte es ein Dammbruch werden, dass halt Sicherheitspolitiker das als Anlass nehmen, die Debatte weiter zu verschärfen. Und insofern könnte es noch zu einem Dammbruch werden. Das können wir halt noch nicht absehen.
Und Fabian, wieder erste Frage an dich. Wird das die DFL wesentlich verändern, deiner Einschätzung nach?
Was meinst du damit, wird es die DFL verändern?
Also wird sich daran jetzt ein Streit entzünden, der zu neuen Solidargemeinschaftsdefinitionen führt innerhalb der DFL? Oder werden die einfach diese 15 bis 20 Millionen zahlen, die es ja erstmal mutmaßlich sein sollen? Und dann ist es vielleicht dann doch in fünf Jahren, wenn wir zurückblicken, gar nicht das große Thema gewesen.
Na ich denke mal schon, dass sich da ein bisschen was bewegen wird. Oder jedenfalls hoffe ich, dass es der Fall ist. Hängt ja auch so ein bisschen davon ab, ob andere Bundesländer jetzt nachziehen und dem Bremer Beispiel folgen. Und dann sprechen wir natürlich über eine ganz andere Belastung. Und dann muss ich sagen, Tarek Brauer ist da durchaus zuzustimmen. Also dann muss sich da in der DFL quasi eine Solidargemeinschaft bilden. Und dann muss auch RB Leipzig, ich weiß gar nicht, ob die überhaupt Risikospiele haben, weil die sind zwar nicht so beliebt, aber so richtige Feinschaften mit Fans gibt's da ja glaube ich gar nicht. Dann müssen die eben auch eins sein.
Innerheits-Leipzig glaube ich, aber ansonsten auch.
Aber dann muss sozusagen jeder, der im Übrigen auch zu dieser Wirtschaftsgemeinschaft Liga gehört, der muss dann eben seinen Beitrag dafür leisten. Also das wird schon diskutiert werden, glaube ich.
Philipp?
Auch wieder da. Menno, also kann ich jetzt ohne Weg dazu sagen, es stimmt, bin ich genauso. Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass es noch weiter ausstrahlt. Denn wenn wir jetzt andere Debatten innerhalb der DFL geführt werden, zum Beispiel um die TV-Rechte und die Mittelverteilung, ist jetzt schon so meine Wahrnehmung, dass man sehr nach dem moral high ground sucht. Also sei es die Argumentation, wir wirtschaften so gut und ihr nicht, wenn wir bestraft oder wir sind team marktwert, daher kam vorhin mein kurzer Einwurf und bei uns ist ja alles viel schöner und viel besser. Da macht man jetzt natürlich, da liefert das Urteil oder sozusagen die Bestätigung, dass diese Kostenfolge grundsätzlich okay ist. Natürlich ein gutes Argument zu sagen, Moment mal, so moral high ground ist das jetzt aber gar nicht. Und vielleicht verschiebt das mittelfristig auch was in dem Bereich. Das wird man sehen müssen.
Und wie glaubt ihr, wird sich das auf Fans, die Spiele besuchen, auswirken, Fabian? Klar ist, dass wir spekulieren müssen, aber es geht ja quasi um dein Gefühl dafür.
Na ja, es kommt jetzt drauf an, von welchem Fan wir sprechen. Meinst du mich beispielsweise?
Du musst zu Hause bleiben.
Ich glaub, auf mich wirkt sich das nicht aus. Also ich hab ehrlich gesagt auch noch bis auf ein einziges Mal noch nie eine unschöne Erfahrung bei Fußballspielen gemacht. Und ich glaub auch ansonsten, wir hatten es ja eingangs schon gesagt, also die, die gewaltbereit sind und sich da unbedingt prügeln wollen, auf die wird es gar keinen Einfluss haben, weil diese von Lage der Nation unterstellte Idee des Fans, ich schad jetzt aber meinem Verein und jetzt auch erst recht, also die gibt es jedenfalls bei denen, die sich die Ärger machen wollen, gibt es das nicht.
Also ich meinte mit Fans jetzt natürlich die Stadionbesucherinnen und Besucher, aber da bist du jetzt ja dann quasi hingekommen. Philipp, hast du ein Gefühl dafür, wie sich das...
Da bleib ich jetzt konsequent von dem, was ich vorher gesagt hab. Ich glaub, da wird sich wenig ändern an der Stelle. Das ist das Einzige, was passieren könnte, dass wir vielleicht jetzt keine Auswärtsfahrten haben an manchen Stellen. So schlimm, wie das sich das anhört.
So schlimm, wie das auch ist. Das ist ja auf EU-Ebene, sprich UEFA mein ich jetzt in dem Fall, ist das ja scheinbar schon akzeptiert, dass es jetzt auch einfach lokale Gesetzgebung geben darf, die dann immer danach durch Gerichte aufgehoben wird. Also sprich Gästefans dürfen nicht anreisen, weil ich verbiet das jetzt einfach. Die bekommen Betretungsverbot für ganze Städte und sieben Monate später sagt ein Gericht, ja, das hättet ihr gar nicht machen dürfen. Und dann ist es aber egal, weil dann ist das Fußballspiel schon mit vorbei. Das ist eine aktuelle Entwicklung, die es zu sehen gibt. Da gibt es Beispiele, die sich immer mehr anhäufen. Also das wird auch zum Beispiel einfach akzeptiert. Hört man auch keine Richterstattung drüber. Ist auch nicht schön, weil da müsstest du auch manchmal für Fans argumentieren, die halt dann vielleicht dann doch keine weißen Kinder sind. Und das ist dann eben einfacher, vielleicht auch gar nicht drüber zu reden oder zu sagen, ja, recht so, dass sie nicht dorthin dürfen. Bleibt noch die Frage, wie gesagt, wir bleiben weiter im Spekulativen. Anders könnte es gar nicht sein. Wie wird sich das auf Polizeitaktikengrund um Fußballspiele ausweiten? Fabian, rechnest du damit, dass das zumindest transparenter wird, was ein Hochrisikospiel ist und was nicht?
Na ja, also das wird wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen davon abhängen, wie der, inwieweit der Rechtsstaat jetzt wieder in Anspruch genommen wird. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Polizei jetzt in ihren Voreinschätzungen da ein bisschen dezidierter sagen wird, wieso und warum sie jetzt der Meinung ist, sie müssten mit dieser Mannstärke auffahren. Aber spätestens dann, wenn es einen Verein gibt oder die DFL gibt, die mal diese Kosten und den Einsatz in Frage stellt und dafür dann vielleicht eben auch den Gerichtsweg bestreitet, kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass das dann gewisse Effekte hat. Oder im Rahmen solcher Verfahren dann einfach eine Rolle spielt, inwieweit die Polizei da transparent war, was ihre Prognose angeht.
Philipp?
Ja, genau. Das ist, ich meine, wenn es um das Verwaltungsgericht geht, also wenn, das ist ja die erste Frage, ob die DFL sowas überhaupt forcieren würde. Also wenn ich ein Verein wäre und ich kriege diese Kostennote, ja vielen Dank für unsere Leistung berechnen, 24.000 Euro, dann wäre ich am nächsten Tag beim Verwaltungsgericht, weil das muss man tun. Die DFL hätte zumindest genutzt so viel finanziellen Bauchspekt, dass sie es über sich ergehen lassen könnten und regeln es dann intern. Aber wenn es vor Gericht geht, ich meine, es gibt ja keine kleine, keine Verwaltungsverfahren, da gibt es keine Beweislast in diesem Sinne. Aber ich meine, Tatbestandsvoraussetzung muss halt sein. Es ist zu erwartende, also erfahrungsmäßig zu erwartende Gewalthandlung und vorhersehbare Erforderlichkeit. Und das ist dann auch gerichtlich überprüfbar. Aber sagen wir es mal so, es gibt da, wir Kapitalmarkt-Rechner nennen das Informations-Asymmetrien, die Polizei kann halt schon eine Menge begründen, und das meine ich überhaupt nicht böse, kann schon eine Menge begründen, was man halt einfach so hinnehmen müsste, wenn man nicht selbst sehr tief in der Szene drin ist.
Was auch im Zweifel dann nicht aufgedeckt werden muss. Also wenn die Polizei müsste ja zum Beispiel einfach nur sagen, uns liegen Informationen vor, dass Szene XY hier auftauchen will, und deswegen zahlt ihr jetzt bitte den Wasserwerfer. Wie willst du dagegen argumentieren? Und will man überhaupt dagegen argumentieren? Weil eigentlich wollen wir ja, dass die Polizei ihre Aufgabe erfüllt. Es gilt nur, wie in allen Bereichen, in allen Gesellschaftsbereichen, ein gesundes Misstrauen gegenüber allen, denjenigen, die irgendwie ein Gewaltmonopol in irgendeiner Art und Weise innehaben, weil es eben auch zu falschen Entscheidungen, Fehleinschätzungen und manchmal vielleicht auch gelenkten Fehleinschätzungen kommt, um mal so im ganz Wagen zu bleiben. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das weitergeht. Ich selbst tue mich auch schwer, zu einem Fazit zu kommen. Ich finde es nur interessant, also ich wusste schon, dass wenn ich mit euch beiden über dieses Thema rede, dass wir anders über dieses Thema reden, als in vielen Teilen der Berichterstattung, die ich gelesen habe. Und gleichzeitig wird das Bild noch komplexer. Ich habe es schon zu Philipp im Vorgespräch gesagt. Je länger man sich damit befasst, desto verworrener wird das Ganze, desto weniger eindeutig sind die Positionen. Ich bewundere diejenigen, die das schaffen, nach so einem Polizeikosten-Urteil dann zu sagen, das ist das Ende des Fußballs oder das ist jetzt ganz, ganz schlimm. Und auch diejenigen, die sagen, das ist absolut exakt so genau richtig ohne Widerspruch. Und hat es endlich mal jemand, den die Hooligans gezeigt. Ich bewundere all diejenigen, die das so sehen können. Ich habe den Eindruck, ganz so einfach ist es nicht, zumindest mir fällt es nicht leicht, da so etwas herauszuziehen aus diesem Urteil. Ich würde euch gerne noch die Möglichkeit geben für letzte Worte, falls es noch irgendetwas gibt, weil ich auch über den juristischen Teil so ein bisschen drüber gehudelt bin. Ehrlich gesagt, das wäre jetzt in keiner Vorlesung von dir durchgegangen, Philipp. Und auch in keinem Liebling Bosmann Podcast wäre das durchgegangen, Fabian. Fabian, du darfst gerne wieder beginnen. Gibt es noch irgendetwas, was dir noch auf der Seele liegt zu diesem Thema?
Also da wir ja noch eine Liebling Bosmann Folge offen haben, wo wir dieses Thema auch besprechen werden, wird dann möglicherweise dein geheimer Wunsch erfüllt, wo wir sozusagen ein bisschen mehr noch in die juristischen Details gehen. Gleichwohl muss ich aber auch sagen, das ist am Ende auch aus meiner Sicht nach wie vor eine politische, gesellschaftliche Frage oder viele, viele Fragen, die sich hier auftun. Und es wäre schön, wenn man es so gelöst bekommen hätte, anstatt hier den Rechtsweg zu gehen. Nur als Jurist weiß ich natürlich auch, dass es manchmal zwanzläufig ist, dass man das macht. Und am Ende eigentlich auch fast immer irgendwas bewegt, wenn man den Rechtsweg geht, insbesondere wenn man ihn zu Ende geht. Weil sich dadurch dann eben neue Türen öffnen, für neue Ideen und vielleicht irgendwie verhärtete Fronten irgendwie nochmal öffnen können. Das wäre meine Hoffnung, weil ich glaube nicht, das hatte ich vorhin schon auch gesagt, dass wir in den nächsten Jahren das Pen-Gewalt-Problem gelöst kommen. Auch nicht mit diesem Urteil.
Ein doch irgendwie positiver Ausblick. Philipp, kannst du da uns draufschlagen?
Wie immer, es ist ja inzwischen eingespielt. Ich hab ja eine Beipflichtung. Und da gibt es juristische Fragen, die zum Beispiel als Anregung, wenn ihr es dann ein bisschen weiter aufdröselt. Ich finde zum Beispiel im Urteil so ganz klar getrennt, also manchmal wird da halt von den Gewinnen und der Profiten und sowas gesprochen, also eher diese monetäre Ansatz. Und dann wird mal wieder von Gefahren und Gewalt und sonst was gesprochen. Ich finde in allen Urteilen geht das manchmal so ein bisschen durcheinander und hier auch. Aber das wird hier wahrscheinlich, da hast du recht Max, ein bisschen sehr zu weit führen. Ich sehe solche Sachen immer ein bisschen als Chance. Vielleicht gibt es mehr Transparenz. Vielleicht setzt sich die DFL da mal ein bisschen zusammen. Aber ich hoffe und ich wiederhole mich damit, dass Politik und Medien das nicht als Ball aufnehmen, um halt noch weiter eine Sicherheitsspirale zu drehen. Ich habe es vorhin begründet. Auf den unmittelbaren Einsatz, glaube ich, wird es wenig, also auf den einen Risikospieleinsatz nicht so viel Einfluss haben, aber insgesamt auf die Tonalität natürlich schon. Weil wenn man es verkürzt, kann man sagen, haha, wir hatten Recht und die Fans nicht. Und das ist nicht gut.
Das ist wirklich nicht gut. Gut war es allerdings mit zwei so tollen Experten sprechen zu dürfen wie euch beiden. Ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Philipp Maume von der TU München und Fabian Reinholz von der Kanzlei Herting und von Liebling Bossmann. Ich werde natürlich auch verlinken, wo man euch folgen kann. Ich werde generell, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ein paar Links in die Show Notes packen, Quellen, die ich verwendet habe bei der Recherche, weiterführende Artikel. Es wird eine Auswahl sein, denn es gab sehr viel Berichterstattung. Aber ich glaube, wenn euch das Thema interessiert, dann klickt dort oder wartet einfach die paar Tage, bis Liebling Bossmann dann draußen ist dazu. Dann habt ihr nochmal ganz, ganz viele Details. Also herzlichen Dank euch beiden. Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörern und Hörern. Denn ihr wisst ja, ihr habt diese Sendung hier möglich gemacht. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe-paywall und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Und in dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Juli, bei DK, bei Nille Vanille, RBL Glubberer, bei Levan Karm, Magisama, FC Fabian, Blauelilli und bei Lukas1912. Sie alle sind auf rasenfunk.de gegangen, haben auf unterstützen geklinkt und uns dann etwas überwiesen, etwas zukommen lassen und sich registriert als Supporterinnen und Supporter. Tut es ihnen gleich für unabhängigen Sportjournalismus, der sich auch ein bisschen Zeit nehmen kann. Es würde mich sehr freuen. Ganz ganz herzlichen Dank an alle, die das schon getan haben. Bleibt gesund, bleibt uns gebogen. Bis bald. Das war der Rasenfunk.
Von Ihnen unterstützt.
Herzlichen Dank.